[Music]
[Music]
spider-man used to make me feel safe now
I'm afraid to walk home from work my son
thought the world of this guy I have a
nine-year-old daughter loved spider-man
who she's supposed to look up to now
this is the guy that gave the key to the
city - I'm gonna put some dirt in your
eye
[Music]
Cheers the newspaper talking I just got
lucky this is so wonderful for you
well you might want to tell JJ to make a
little more wall space
[Music]
oh good morning it's beautiful day huh
what was it you said I'll never get that
picture there's your hero huh I never
thought he'd really do that see right
there you made a judgment call you gotta
see it as it is it's funny you should
say that because I was looking through
some old photos in it looks very similar
okay fine get back to work you trash
Brock excuse me your pictures of fake
now Parker you are such a boy scout what
are you gonna give a guy a break you
want forgiveness get religious yeah no
way
we're just horsing around look I'm
begging you if you do this I will lose
everything
there's not a paper in town that will
hire me you should have thought of that
earlier
what are you doing Peter show this to
your editor tell him to check his source
next time
[Music]
it's a fake
Empire State photographic Department
confirms it pack your things get out of
my building oh it's just your fire you
know we're gonna have to print a
retraction now I've been printed a
retraction in 20 years
you
you